[Musique]
la planète shadoks est infestée par la
maladie cosmique les uns rétrécissent
les autres grâce aux vaccins du
professeur shadow qu éclate
pendant ce tour dans le cosmos le jpy
son chapeau pilotait la fusée comme un
fou sans s'occuper de rien et fonçait
droit sur la planète shadoks et la
terrible maladie
malheureux ce n'est toujours pour un
chat d'oc
il voulait retourner dans sa famille il
voyait des lumières sur la planète
shadow qu'ils croyaient qu'on tirait des
feux d'artifice pour l'accueillir
qu'elle s'était pas ça du tout c'étaient
les shadoks inoculé qui éclatent est de
loin bien sûr ça faisait bien mais de
près
quelle pitié la maladie d'abord les
contaminer les réfléchissez ils ne
mouraient pas tous mais ceux qui
survivent est le professeur shadow coach
s'était dit celui pour les inoculé
les shadoks évidemment essayer de se
cacher ils se camouflent et en importe
quoi en passoire
[Musique]
en ressort deux lits poêle où on
arrosoir pour échapper au terrible fléau
ou au vaccin le professeur chan au cou
mais rien n'y faisait et la maladie au
gré pour les uns comme pour les autres
la situation dans son ensemble
commençait à être assez désespérée
[Musique]